ready loop l1 over hearts on Jojo season  of The Bachelorette the war veteran was  even the frontrunner to be next season's  bachelor it's a possibility  now each you've learned why Luke might  have been passed over for Nick vile  multiple sources tell eg the 31 year  olds hopes of launching a country music  career became his priority a major cause  for concern to producers singer a  songwriter a song well you did already a  whole album  Luke told eg he was blindsided when  producers decided to go with Nick but et  has learned it's standard to have  multiple people signed contracts before  the show's lead is chosen this is not  supposed to be happening et has reached  out to Luke for comment ok guys what do  you think will Nick make a better choice  than Luke or were you hoping to see Luke  searching for love next season let's  talk over on Twitter and eyebrow